you've got to do your job you've got to
do your job how are you good to see you
we're asking everyone blink once if you
live blink twice if you die stare
straight ahead if you can't tell me
anything I don't understand this is the
night you can finally give it up how
crazy were they about keeping these
secrets no I love the way they keep see
asking you spoiler questions yes this
interviews over they are excellent at
keeping secrets
excellent so we all fall in line I hope
I hope what can you tell me about Black
Panther - have you guys heard and what
we got we want to do it we would love to
do your Black Panther to you but if
something happens that is crazy we might
not see any any other any other of
anything we do know according to the
comics eventually you become Black
Panther yeah she does but then you have
the Russo brothers and their ideas and
that can change everything but
eventually you become like banther you
keep digging a hole that you're not
gonna get out of Lucy I'm just I'm just
so excited to see the movie the first
love for whoever it was the Black
Panther leading into Avengers were so
major
so to see I want to see what this film
is gonna do how much fun is the press
tour been traveling around the world how
crazy is it so for me I didn't get to go
on this on this tour because you know we
are the fallen so it's the ones that are
living right now that get to do it so
this is the first time and the first
thing I'm getting to do to see the
experience and yeah so I'm excited hmm I
can be judged Judy
I'm just good I'm good you are so damn
good
[Music]